what you might remember back in June
Clark County Commissioners voted to pass
some new regulations on short-term
rentals now those changes caused massive
concern for hosts all across the valley
in fact so much so that one Association
sued the county claiming several of the
regulations were unconstitutional while
on Monday the district court agreed with
them so what's next Madison Kimbrough
spoke with those involved and joins us
now with the details
many short-term rental hosts feeling
relieved tonight after the ruling
stating that with the regulations in
place many feared that they would have
to shut down and that was on the minds
of many
well you know I'm breathing a little
easier because I think we really needed
to get that injunction short-term rental
host and the greater Las Vegas
short-term rental Association feeling
Victorious after the district court
granted them preliminary injunction
against the county in regards to their
regulations on short-term rentals passed
in June the County's ordinance states
that properties must allow County
inspections without notice and hosts
must enter a lottery system in order to
obtain a short-term rental license large
Gatherings of more than 10 people would
not be allowed reservations must have a
minimum of a two-night stay rentals must
also be a thousand feet away from each
other these regulations not sitting well
with host and Clark County as many feel
it's keeping them from running a
successful business and making a decent
income it's just totally blown out of
proportion of the county you know then
it's not fair
you know why why can't I make money off
my room there's people that are simply
trying to make ends meet there's people
trying to put their kids through college
there's people that have elderly parents
that are now sick and need to be put in
Assisted Living short-term rentals are a
great way to make that income necessary
Jackie Flores with glv s t r a says with
the District Court's decision to go back
and review these regulations it makes
her hopeful for the future of short-term
rental hosts in Clark County it feels
really good that finally we have you
know the judge agreeing with us in what
we're saying so now the Dutch is
ordering uh the county and us to work
together to fix the issues with the
ordinance
and the county still doesn't have an
exact date to when they will be giving
out licenses but for those coming into
town for the holiday the current
regulations still apply now in order to
apply for a license here in Clark County
the deadline is in March reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now